[Musique]
il est dans l'armée de l'air
je te garantis que tu n'es pas pris le
revoir je comprends pas pourquoi je
crois que tu le sais très bien
mes parents m'ont envoyé au collège de
mon frère ça craint vous qui faites
partie de cette institution vous allez
tous parvenir au sommet jamais on ne
vous aura fait la moindre faveur ou ne
devrez votre ascension car votre mérite
enchanté qu'est-ce qu'il y a des fois il
y a des élèves qui disent des trucs
méchants sur les enfants noirs c'est qui
celui-là c'est un mec de mon ancienne
école il y en a qui venait chez toi des
fois dans ce cas
tout évidemment je trouve ça
avec ta grand-mère quand on est arrivé
dans ce pays on n'avait pas grand chose
mais pourquoi elle est venue en Amérique
parce qu'on voulait la tuer il y avait
des troubles de soldats et il se mettait
parfois chercher des juifs ils nous
détestait à l'époque il nous déteste
toujours
on a pris le bateau et on a débarqué en
Amérique la terre de tous les rêves
tu as envie que je fasse comme toi je
veux que tu puisses faire
maintenant c'est profiter de la chance
qui était offerte et surtout tu te
retournes là-bas
vous êtes toute ma vie
[Musique]
ça suffit si tu entends encore ces
chemins de dire quoi que ce soit
défendez d'accord
[Musique]
tu sens un vrai mens d'accord une bonne
poignée de main allez fais-moi un câlin